I need you to help me remember what we
did on Tuesday and I've given you a bit
of a cube on the board what was Tuesdays
lessons focus okay so we did two forms
on Tuesday and we said okay look we can
think about these numbers not just like
as as lovers but geometric later we had
a shape meeting for this rectangular
form is the normal way that we write
words like the first way through a very
complex of this is because the X or the
Y each represent the dimensions of a
rectangle right you've got your
horizontal position your vertical
position and you can draw a rectangular
okay but then we also introduced to
respect all this extra effort with tree
to introduce powerful what does colorful
look like like third algebra what would
I write first I'd right ah right what I
call it are you it's the radius we took
where this was on the complex plane
which had another fancy name starting an
edge remember the Argand plane you can
draw it like a diagram on that and we
said look if you put a circle on this
that's the radius right now is the
radius of circle but we gave it a
fancier name to do with complex numbers
started with an M the modulus so we've
got the modulus cut up the front right
and then you've got various other stuff
what's the other stuff that cos theta
very good so you've got your real
component and you've got your imaginary
component right so we're thinking of
this not just in terms of a horizontal
vertical displacement but in terms of
how far are you away from the origin
which is the real meaning of absolute
value not just take the pod upon and
which way you're facing right you want
to go some distance away well which
which way you're going to go that
distance
that's what Phoebe tells you now it took
us some effort to do that right
usually in that place reflector Rapids
with shorter not longer so it seems like
a substantial downgrade to go for a
rectangle form to polar form so today
we're going to answer the Commissioner
answer the question of what why do this
why is it worthwhile okay just like with
straight lines each one has a point to
it each one is like here's the intention
behind this ball so what's the intention
behind probable now like she draw
another number line for me if you
haven't already this is just the real
number line now on the real number line
I want you to remember we thought about
all of the operations on here and we
feel that they're geometric meaning okay
and the particular one I wanna focus on
today is multiplication so if I took
three if you'll notice as well I'm
writing it I'm drawing it rather as more
than just a point okay
I'm representing it as this line with
the direction a direction and also a
magnitude okay the reason why I'm trying
through all that parallel is because
polar form also has a direction that's
the that's the theta part which way you
facing and it has a magnitude right so
that's the argue so this is three has a
direction imagine if I were to multiply
this by two if I were to multiply as
much food what would that become it just
becomes six so I've got a new arrow that
I'm gonna put on here this way if I
multiply by two okay so I want you to
build language to you or really is
rather I said to be that real numbers
can all be thought of as stale as it's
just a just a single number but complex
numbers need to be thought of as vectors
right it's not just that there's a size
to this number but there's a size of is
a direction okay and this line here
indicates what the vector is doing so
these for all intents and purposes this
straight Levenberg are vectors so I have
a new vector and we said multiplication
is you scale and you scale in a certain
direction okay what if I multiply by
negative two
where would I go I'm going to same
magnitude right but from here I'm going
to be facing all the way
one two three four five six good right
I've scaled again but I've scaled in a
different direction okay now this is
going to help us wrap our heads around
why all the form is so useful we're
going to need to do another
multiplication here this time that's
doing a rectangle form and just see what
happens okay so here's my example let's
consider I'm going to give you a pair of
complex numbers okay now I've already
handed them to you rectangular for to
make it a little easier just turn your
head multiply this is just arithmetic is
it isn't it would you go ahead would you
multiply these guys out and then when
you've got an answer I want you to take
these three complex numbers Zen's a
complex number don't use a complex
number and Z W is going to be a third
complex number I want you to take all
three of them and then plot them on two
and I'll get diagram try and make it
reasonably accurate you don't have to
make it super accurate but that all
accurate your diagram is the more you'll
be able to see the point of what going
to be this person is demonstrates okay
go ahead and do that do you get a middle
okay so by now have a strong long enough
you probably saw the arithmetic he was
not complicated right you might have
noticed suspiciously that your real
parts here in here right seem to just
cancelled out that's kind of nice you
have a look at how much of an imaginary
unit you've got left
there's nine on two of the three on two
of them that's 12 or two so your total
of course is six that's your whole
number okay so you've got this comic
stuff about this one and you've got a
last one so you can see our time to plot
these Anki I just don't I don't know as
we draw this on here each of these
points each of these points I'm
representing with a real number and a
column a generic oval right so you've
got each of the components there well
you have a look at this guy over here
it's fine just to write that as 6 pi ok
so that's like where it is however when
you have a look at what the axes are
this is not like when I would label
these old label is is 1 2 3 4 & 5 on
axis because each of those residents
became how many imaginary units do you
have okay 1 2 3 etc having really good
do you have okay
however when I talk about the point
which just happens to be on the actors
the point itself is exact
okay right now to help us wrap our heads
around what is going on let's do the
same thing we did over here and
understand that these are not just poets
they are vectors right so let's go ahead
and draw the connection like that arrow
that says probably origin how do you get
to that complex number okay so here is Z
there's the vector representing said
here is W and then Z W our product is
all the way oh yeah okay now I hope some
of you have already converted these
numbers into modern form into polar form
what's the first one and someone goes it
okay
so you've got that first one so you know
its radius you know is the direction and
that matches you can say it's like oh
yeah that's two units away and this
angle here right Pilon six that's 30
degrees and if you drew like I said if
you diagram reasonably accurately you
can see it Oh what about this second one
what's it in polar form three yes three
what
okay fantastic and just to round it out
the simplest of all of them okay 6i it
seems a bit true yours like it's it's so
simple what I write it in a more complex
way complex but it's not that hard to
interpret how far am I what's the
modulus it's just going to be six people
you can just read it off okay so that's
going to be six and then what's the
argument that comes along for the ride
yeah good we're measuring from the
positive real axis by the way just a
little side note I don't know if you
guys found it as confusing as I did when
I first learnt it but when you read
compass bearings when you read compass
bearings you'd--you'd north south east
west so we did true bearings right we
read them from north and then we read
clockwise all right that's the way we do
compass bearings okay and then some
genius decided oh now that we're doing
like when you're doing
all stations to central and you're you
know measuring out your quadrants of
that company they're like hey you know
what forget north let's start from
somewhere else right and you know just
for the walls let's measure the other
direction
right let's just go anti-clockwise cuz
why not it's kind of like that you know
it's like the u.s. we drive on the right
side of the road because everyone else
tries on the left-hand side of the road
now you can see actually it's not
arbitrary right people who only know
where real numbers never find out really
why the reason why we do this
anti-clockwise is because on the complex
plane right
you'd have to measure from you because
that's where the real plane the real
numbers to start and you're just
measuring up right 2 PI R 2 cos pi/2 it
makes sense okay yes yes that's a great
question okay so um tan theta equals
suit on 0 this is a problem isn't it and
the reason why is because when you think
about do you remember when I came back
to
this here so all of that people on the
unit circle okay no ten is useful but
Tannen he comes in because will you tend
to have the opposite and adjacent
science namely based you guys okay
but we know that tan is not defined
where is tend not to find how well do
you guys know your tan graph okay you
should know at mater is or rather lose
PI on to right and then at two hundred
seventy or rather three point two you
have these discontinuities right and
then you've got the rest of the shape
now what that represents is that planet
two and three planets you on this
diagram that's here appear everywhere on
the imaginary axis positive and three
pointers down here there's no run
there's no horizontal distance that's
what ten is right um it's sign of a
close slider because it's rise everyone
that's why we call the tangent but
because it gives you the gradient okay
so that's why it's not to find it so
instead just don't worry about using ten
just remember it's just in terms of
these guys and of course cost PI over
two is zero so that's why it's under
five okay okay so good we see what's
going on can you see the relationship
here right over here we said that
multiplication is about two things
scaly like how far do you want to go
away right and what was the other thing
scale and direction okay now here on the
real number line the only directions
you've got our forwards and backwards
that's it okay but now we have this
whole universe of directions that we've
got you and I hope you can see how the
numbers into play with each other right
the same scaling is happening it's not a
coincidence did you notice right two
times three equals six right one of the
directions how do they respond to each
other
however these angles here are related to
these angles you just add them up right
can you see you see over here there's
your PI on 6 and if you add PI on three
to it that's what gets you to PI 2 now
this is interesting but this is just an
example in mathematics we don't do proof
by example I could give you a million
examples and I really need one
counterexample and I've been disproved
your theory ok so I need more than just
an example I need to be able to prove
this beyond the shadow of a doubt not
just for these particular moduli and
these particular arguments but for any
modulus and Eddie are you